our leaders have never been safer or
more secure the federal areas of
washington dc look like the green zone
in baghdad nothing bad happens there
the capitol police now have a bigger
budget than the police departments of
detroit or atlanta
but just outside this wonderland where
our lawmakers live ten cities are
popping up
everywhere in dc and cities across the
country
those cities are full of drugs weapons
and human waste they're ignored but not
by our kevin cork
he's got a story on it hey kevin evening
tucker this is uh
frankly a shocking reality here the
nation's capital homeless encampments as
you point out
once relegated to pockets or quadrants
of the city now encroaching
on once well-heeled neighborhoods and
neither the local nor national
government seem compelled to act
latest example homeless encampments in
the shadow of the venerable watergate
which for now will stay according to
authorities despite furious local
complaints about drugs
harassment human excrement and even
weapons
similar camps have sprung up near the
city's burke park gumpers park
ninth and mass and right in the heart of
dupont circle and yet
despite repeated pleas to intervene over
public safety concerns
the city national park police and the
u.s park police
at least for now are refusing to
dismantle those camps
this is by the way the city which has a
burgeoning violence problem
spiking in fact over the past year with
murders surging in the city and
shootings happening
outside of nationals park and even over
on 14th street which is a very popular
restaurant neighborhood here in
washington
and tucker perhaps the most
disheartening part of what's happening
here is
it doesn't appear to be any sort of
righteous indignation or vocal criticism
of the city's leadership that you would
certainly expect
even as this once proud city continues
to suffer tucker
kevin cork thank you for noticing that i
appreciate it you bet
so it's not just washington dc in fact
across the country cities are in trouble
but particularly in the state of
minnesota
now minnesota for many years was so
tranquil that people laughed about
all those nice scandinavians they
actually mocked minnesota for being too
nice
not anymore in a town just southwest of
minneapolis a woman was beheaded on
video in broad daylight and left in the
street
shakopee police were called to that
intersection a search warrant reveals
when they arrived they found thayer's
decapitated body
lying on the ground next to a car
authorities say they have a suspect in
custody
who multiple people tell fox nine was in
a long-term relationship with
thayer where domestic abuse was a
consistent problem
court records reveal the suspect was
convicted on domestic assault charges in
2017
and was facing arson charges for
allegedly trying to burn his apartment
down
on the most recent charges he was
released on 50 thousand dollars bond
this spring
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else